here's what would happen if the earth  was shaped like an american football  a planet like this actually exists it's  called wasp 121b it's shaped like this  because it's in such close proximity to  its star  if earth happened to be shaped like this  football planet it would be extremely  hot all our glaciers would melt and  poison our atmosphere with elevated  methane levels the sea levels would rise  and force people to relocate from the  flooded coasts  as the greenhouse gases increased our  planet would heat up to about  462 degrees celsius as you can imagine  no life could inhabit a planet this hot  but what if the earth was able to take  the shape of a football and skip the  extreme heat well earth would have to  rotate faster in order to keep that  shape resulting in shorter days secondly  the poles would have lower gravity and  the gravitational pull at the equator  would be stronger  but life would still go on so